Nå får vi se hva som sker.
Ok, perfect, so we can press play here
And if you want to pause, you can also pause and press the spacebar
Ok
So this first high kick, I felt like I kind of swung it
I landed in a little bit too short of a stance
This front part was ok
I thought my movements could have been more sharp
Here I felt I had to prepare for the side kick
And again, it felt a little bit swingy
But I didn't lose balance
So here I felt a little bit relieved since all the side kicks were over
And now I got a chance to breathe
And I wasn't worried about this last part
So I felt more confident from now on
So I pushed it and came back to the starting position
And then I went over to the side kick
And sat back down
And I'm back to the beginning
And the knee rest
And I'm back on the ground